يبلغ حجم الجليد عادةً حوالي خمسة
سنتيمترات عندما أتزلج عليها ، هذا
الصوت الذي تسمعه هو في الواقع مزيج
من صوتين ، أصواتهما من
الشقوق التي تضرب تحتي
والاهتزازات داخل الصفيحة الجليدية نفسها
، يبدو الأمر وكأنه شيء أسرع من الصوت
يلتقي مورتن أينار مرحباً I  مورتن آينار
هو عالم رياضيات يستمتع بهوايات أكثر خطورة
من معظم الناس الذين أمارسوا التزلج على
الجليد الرقيق لأربعين عامًا عندما كان
يتزلج على الرغم من أنه يستمع أيضًا ،
ضع في اعتبارك أن الجليد أعلى
الملعب عندما ينكسر الجليد تقريبًا
وسيكون ذلك  حوالي ثلاثة سنتيمترات
من الملعب في أعلى درجة ، من
المفترض أنهم أعلى ملاحظة لهذا ،
يعتمد مورتن الواعد على معرفته
كعالم رياضيات لحساب
سمك الجليد ، إنه مرونته
ودرجة حرارته يميل كثير من الناس إلى
الفزع عندما يرون  أتزلج على
الجليد الرقيق ولكني لا أستطيع أن أكون أكثر هدوءًا
لأنني أعرف ما أفعله أحيانًا
يكون الجليد صافياً تمامًا ويمكنني أن أرى
سمكة تنفخ حتى سمور  وأيضًا الغواصين الأحرار الذين
يسبحون تحت الجليد عندما
بدأ مارتن لأول مرة ، لم يكن هناك أي معلومات
فيزيائية أو علمية
تشرح مدى إمكانية التزحلق على الجليد الرقيق ،
فقد درس الجليد لمدة عشر سنوات كل
شتاء لشرح الظاهرة التي لاحظت
[موسيقى]
بها ثلاثة أشياء  الجليد الرقيق
هو أن الجليد ينحني
وكلما أرق كلما احتاجت الأذرع
إلى أن تكون مرنة لدعمك
ثانيًا ، الكراك الأول هو إشارة تحذير حقيقية ،
ثم أعرف أن الجليد رقيق
وعندما يصبح أرق ، المزيد من
الشقوق  تتطور أخيرًا ، يعطي الجليد
نغمة رنانة نغمة غريبة جميلة ، أي
الوسائط تخبرني بمدى سماكة الجليد
الذي يُطلق عليه تواتر الصدفة
ويمكن حسابه رياضيًا ،
ويتزلج الخشب على أكثر من 1800 مسطح
مائي في أمريكا الشمالية والنرويج
وأوروبا الوسطى والشرقية التي أحبها
التزحلق على الجليد من أجل الإثارة
والتحديات التي يجلبها ، إنها
فرصة لإتقان الطبيعة للالتقاء معًا
وجعلها مفهومة بالنسبة لي لقد كنت
أتزلج معظم
حياتي وأنا أتطلع دائمًا إلى الأسبوع المقبل